en 2019 il avait été reconnu coupable de
la séquestration puis du viol d'elodie
kulik une jeune femme assassinée en 2002
à partir de ce lundi jusqu'au 2 juillet
willy bardon est jugé en appel à douai
dans le nord
retour en images sur une affaire
longtemps est résolu elle était la plus
jeune directrice des agences bancaires
de france
le destin brisé d'elodie kulik tout
commence dans la nuit du 10 au 11
janvier 2002 elodie kulik 24 ans rentre
chez elle en voiture après un dîner
c'est à ce moment là qu'elle est
projetée sur le bas-côté d'une route
dans le département de la somme
elodie kulik roule sur la départementale
44 en direction de theron sa peugeot 106
a été retrouvée vide et accidenté dans
un champ où elle a effectué plusieurs
tonneaux à la hauteur de karting après
son accident
la jeune femme a eu le temps de
contacter les pompiers sur l'appel on
entend aussi de voix d'hommes mais dans
la voiture aucune trace d'elodie son
corps est retrouvé le 12 janvier à 6 km
de la terre tripes
un agriculteur fait la macabre
découverte avant de prévenir le maire de
la commune peut dépasser en vitesse ci
s'est pas présenté mais il a vu que
c'était quand même un corps humain qui
ressemblait à ce qu'il avait vu sur le
sur le journal avant de venir en plus
d'avoir été brûlés elodie kulik a été
violée et étranglée
l' enquête démarre un adn et découvert
sur le lieu du crime
mais pendant dix ans les recherches
restent infructueuses il faut attendre
le 16 janvier 2012 pour qu'un des
agresseurs soit identifiée il s'agit
d'un homme de 22 ans décédé dans un
accident de la route
un an après le meurtre de la jeune femme
son nom grégory viard ses relations de
l'époque sont mis sur écoute janvier
un homme est mis en examen willy bardon
il est suspecté d'avoir participé au
meurtre d'elodie des proches ont reconnu
sa voix sur l'enregistrement fait aux
pompiers pour jacky kulik le père de la
victime
c'est un soulagement pour moi je suis
vraiment quelque chose de mal et j'ai
que joueur opl court au début de
l'enquêté on n'avait pas grand chose à
nos de haine qui n'étaient pas fichés et
puis la bande sur lequel l audi opel
le procès de willy bardon s'ouvre le 20
novembre 2019 à amiens mais à l'annoncé
de son jugement
coup de théâtre il tente de se suicider
en ingérant du technique un pesticide
très toxique
on n'a pas d'explication je pense que la
volonté qui est la sienne c'est pas
supporté la prison finalement son état
s'améliore après plusieurs jours passés
dans le coma ou liebart dont a été
condamné à 30 ans de réclusion
criminelle
il fera appel de cette décision
[Musique]